many of the people
that did this violently storming the u.s
capitol
terrorizing the people inside say this
was just the beginning
social media posts suggesting in the
coming days as the presidential
inauguration gets closer
there will be a repeat in washington d.c
and in state capitals
across the country this threat is real
it's present
and the american public should know that
law enforcement is working around the
clock
to make sure that this threat is kept at
bay but if they come
this is what they will find as many as
twenty thousand national guard soldiers
some armed surrounding federal buildings
sleeping in the hallways between shifts
a heavy police presence and heavy
equipment
the top leadership of the military
taking the unprecedented step of sending
out this letter to the entire military
reminding them they are bound to support
and defend the constitution
and that joe biden will be the 46th
commander-in-chief
and there are renewed calls for people
to stay away from the inauguration
airbnb taking the unusual step of
canceling all d.c
rentals for the event we have asked
americans
not to come to the washington d.c event
but
instead to participate virtually
inside the capitol members now asked to
pass through metal detectors to enter
the chamber
several republicans refusing democrats
are making serious allegations that some
of their political opponents
even colluded with the rioters those
members of congress who had groups
coming through the capitol that i saw on
january
5th are reconnaissance for the next day
those members of congress
that incited this violent crowd the
leader of one of the groups that was at
the capitol says he has been
coordinating with at least three members
of congress
allegations they all deny but any sign
of how polarized this institution has
become
some members like democrat alexandria
ocasio-cortez
now say they were afraid to shelter with
others afraid they would tell the mob
where they were i can tell you that i
had a very close
encounter where i thought i was going to
die
i did not know if i was going to make it
to the end of that day of life
across the country police are being
deployed capitol buildings boarded up
but former cia agent glenn carl says the
u.s capitol
could still be at risk the center of
everything is washington
so if you want to make a statement or if
you're really angry you want to strike
where things are the most important
it's not going to be montpelier vermont
on january 20th this is where joe biden
is expected to take the oath of office
surrounded by images of a country at war
with itself
patty calhane al jazeera washington